now to ukraine and reports of a major
new setback for russian forces the
ukrainian military says it has badly
damaged the flagship of russia's black
sea fleet in a missile attack the
russians say the cruiser was not hit by
ukraine meanwhile residents of tsarnaev
in northern ukraine are returning to
what's left of their homes after a
devastating campaign of shelling and
airstrikes the local mayor says 70
percent of the city was destroyed holly
williams is in ukraine this morning
holly good morning
good morning well ukrainian forces have
so far put up a much tougher resistance
than many people expected aided by some
notable russian military failures but
now ukraine is bracing for a fresh
russian attack in this country's east
these people have fled russia's brutal
invasion at this evacuation centre they
register and get whatever helps
available but they're running short here
of even basic supplies like soap and
toothbrushes
the pain and the anxiety is written in
their faces
she made it out of far eastern ukraine
before an expected russian assault
but her 73 year old husband refused to
come
ukraine's civilians know they're in the
firing line this residential apartment
block was hit in the city of kharkiv
valentina says her next-door neighbor
was killed
and in the shattered city of mariopol
bombarded for weeks on end ukrainian
officials say more than 20 000 are
believed dead russia claims over a
thousand ukrainian troops surrendered
though ukraine denies it
ukraine's military with a fraction of
moscow's forces is still punching above
its weight ukraine claims it's once
again successfully targeted russia's
navy this time the flagship of russia's
black sea fleet the same ship that
ukrainian troops famously told to go to
hell when they were ordered to surrender
at the start of the war
but there's growing frustration in this
country that they haven't been given
more weapons by the west
colonel igor igambardiev a veteran of
ukraine's military told us earlier this
week that the us has given ukraine
enough weapons to prevent its own
destruction but not enough to win the
war freedom must be armed better than
tyranny western countries have
everything to make it happen ukraine's
president vladimir zelinski spelled out
what ukraine wants yesterday with a wish
list of weaponry
artillery 155 millimeters artillery
shells 152 millimeters as many as
possible and a reminder of what he says
is at stake arm ukraine now to defend
freedom
president zielenski has praised
president biden for accusing russia of
genocide here in ukraine saying quote
calling things by their names is
essential to stand up to evil
tony
holly williams on another tense day in
ukraine holly thank you very much